so I had this love for still the
physical especially physical science
that I was trying to use in my studies I
was talking with you to try to get more
into the symbolic quy I was also talking
with John Riki about the cognitive
science side and also in in general he
was great on the the physics side and I
was always trying to bridge mainly
between you and John I would say it took
several years I would often like run
arguments by you and by him and like try
to see if I can make something through
this I developed I think pretty
carefully a path from materialism all
the way to the symbolic world and even
up to the more let's say esoteric
debates in symbolism like how is it
exactly that the world exists in in
Christ and how is it that the world
exists through human consciousness and
like all of these more esoteric kind of
questions this is Jonathan Pedro welcome
to the symbolic
world so hello everyone I am very happy
to be here with JP Mao JP for those who
have followed the channel for a very
long time you've seen him on the channel
for years he was the editor of the
symbolic World blog he's really been uh
a partner in kind of developing a lot of
the symbolic World ideas um and we're
going to launch a course where he's
going to be giving a class called the
metaphysics of symbolism where we're
going to look at the relationship
between uh metaphysical ideas and the
symbolic world as we kind of present it
and also his take on it uh I'll be part
of it to some extent he'll be doing part
of it alone uh and we're also go
announcing that we are going to publish
uh a book on the same subject by JP and
so I'm really happy to see all this
coming together uh he's just been such a
great help all this time to help me
think through because he has such clear
thinking more than I do I get kind of he
has a very kind of clear thinking we've
been doing a French podcast for years
now uh that you can also find on YouTube
if you just write Jonathan peo France
French you can find the you can find the
podcast we'll put a link in the
description so JP it's good to to to see
you and I thought maybe we could start
with you telling people a little bit how
you came to this you know what what your
what Your Story is cuz it's pretty
interesting yeah for sure thanks I never
told it on your channel um basic
background um was really into science um
during my teenage years I had been
raised Catholic in in Quebec classic uh
practicing family but when I was a
teenager drifted away from the faith um
mention science as one of the excuses
let's say to make my parents stop
bringing me to church
um but I was still interested by
questions of meaning um I think these
questions pop up naturally if you um
push let's say the scientific world view
far enough um I was just not very
impressed by the philosophy that I had
seen when I was younger let's say in
high school or a CP that we have here in
uh Quebec so I decided to study math and
computer science in University because I
was mainly interested in mathematical
logic and uh theoretical computer
science there's all kinds of cool
theorems you can prove about certain
formal systems what they can and cannot
uh prove gives you sort of an idea of
how far you can push knowledge in some
areas so anyway I was really interested
by that um but I think like many people
with a basic scientific education what I
ended up sort of inheriting as a side
effect was a materialistic ristic
worldview um where I guess you spend so
many hours like trying to do problems
where you reduce things to their
constituent bits that at some point it's
sort of became normal for me to just see
the world um as particles moving about
and even people like it was hard for me
to see people as something else than
just complex uh sets of particles that
evolved randomly through natural
selection to like have complex behaviors
but fundamentally it's just reducible to
to particles
um and yeah I just add this basic kind
of worldview where it was hard to find
meaning like in my ontology and also
epistemologically in terms of what we
can know um I was really drawn to
mathematics because it seemed like you
can have like sure knowledge of things
in mathematics that that wasn't the case
where um that that wasn't the case for
the philosophy courses I had before like
mostly people were just doubting
everything in philosophy that's what I I
thought back then but at least in math I
could prove stuff so like maybe it's not
obvious how I can talk about meaningful
topics in mathematics but at least we
seem to be going somewhere because like
we seem certain of what we're doing but
even then um in mathematical logic I I I
like Tred to take as many courses as I
could early on to see the proof of a
good incompleteness theorems and now
when I when I saw the proof I saw that
well I guess if within math you can't be
that sure of what you're doing um I had
heard about girdle's famous theorem that
no uh formal system that is coherent
will be complete and I had heard about
it but typically when you have these
really cool sounding theorems in math or
physics like when you actually get to to
them and you see all the postulates that
are required for them they they're
actually not that cool but in that case
that was true like it was really as
devastating as as it sounds so what
ended up happening is like
okay like I had this worldw where I saw
everyone as just bits of matter where it
was hard to find meaning in that and my
knowledge like my access to knowledge in
the world that used to be mediated by
mathematics even that was destroyed by
good old theorem so I was a bit a bit to
drift like like is anything worth doing
really I wasn't doing that bad like it
sounds more depressing than it was it
just it just was great but I thought
like if everything is meaningless anyway
I might as well think about it to make
sure that like I'm not screwing this up
somehow so I decided to do a masters in
the philosophy um especially about
reductionism to try to see if like
something was wrong with my worldview is
reductionism wrong and can we talk about
meaning and um Good and Evil somehow can
we recover that I no expectation at all
that it would work but I thought well if
everything is meaningless anyway as
might as well try you know well there's
literally nothing to lose so uh during
the course of my my Master's um Duran
Peterson up onto the scene and uh as
soon as I heard him talk about meaning
and good and evil in terms that I hadn't
heard before I decided to look into it
um and through that uh I also uh
stumbled upon you I think I
started um I think I started
contributing to your patreon as soon as
right away you one of the first people
that that supported me yeah was crazy
because I I I knew you were doing
something interesting and I wanted to
talk to you because I didn't really
understand what you and Jordan were
doing to be honest but I I wanted like I
wanted some kind of access to to try to
dive into it and I had lots of time
because I was doing my masters in
something related um and one of the
first things we talked about was zombies
because you were having you it was an
existential question for you it wasn't
just a theoretical question yeah exactly
I think uh I wonder how common of a
thing that is like obviously it's
present in the common imagination
because there's lots of zombie movies
and books and and so on but basically if
I think back about this period of my
life while I was studying abstractly
nihilism and materialism during the day
in my studies I would spend like all
night long exploring the same topics
symbolically having zombie nightmares so
like for literally like all night every
night for about a year I had like zombie
nightmares it it's it again sounds worse
than it is like actually what ended up
happening after a while is I sort of
figured out what was like going on like
cuz initially if you just wake up every
time you have such a nightmare like
you'll never sleep so at some point I
sort of understood that it was just like
just yet another zombie nightmare so
like even if I would get eaten or
someone I wouldn't actually wake up I
would just like I knew that I would just
start another dream but it never stopped
so like to just this endless cycle of
zombie nightmares uh but uh I I ended up
getting rid of my zombie problem in part
thanks to you and John Veri uh it was
really a series of of steps um first um
in my studies um
I was looking at
specifically arguments against
materialism and trying to find
alternative ways of uh framing the world
um at that stage specifically I I had
seen enough arguments against
materialism in philosophy that I could
drop materialism and adopt pism at the
time I I thought that was a nice easy
bridge to make and then from there um
started to dive into some and yeah what
I should say is as soon as I did that
the zombie nightmares started to go away
like they were cut down I don't know 50
90% like to to a good extent like they
started to go away I still add them but
it was less frequent and then next step
was diving into a little bit of
classical metaphysics especially with
regards to Virtue ethics um okay if
there isn't just matter in the world if
people aren't just particles uh
following blind laws is
there like also some kind of good and
evil that we can talk about it's not
iMed mediate like just because you're
not a materialist doesn't mean that
you'll necessarily have an ontology that
allows you to speak about Good and Evil
but um through um classical philosophy I
was able to find good Arguments for that
um things you can find in Plato and
Aristotle but also new arguments coming
from cognitive science some of the the
things um that John Riki and Jordan and
you talk about so um like a big thing
for me was realizing that in general
perception is something that we practice
and it's not just our moral perceptions
that we need to practice and improve
it's just our perception of everything
um it's something that we know from
developing infants like initially
infants can't really see like it's
something they really have to practice
um and when when you sort of know that
this happens in infants you can start to
pick that up also in yourself um an
example I always come back to is uh
Brazilian jiu-jitsu or like any complex
sport really like if you look at it
initially you won't see anything like
you'll just see chaos basically like you
know okay at the beginning of the fight
two people like are setting up and at
the end there's one person that's
obviously losing and is tapping out but
you don't see really what happened in
between you don't have the the the
perception to make up the pattern from
the multiplicity of moves going on
literally had that experience that we
talked about it where I'm watching a
match and then all of a sudden the
people that are there are cheering and
I'm like what am I there's not there's
nothing happening I don't see what's
happening like they know that the now
the person is in the right position to
do this or that but I have no idea I'm
just looking and then like you said at
some point one guy loses and I'm like
what the hell just happened I don't know
what I what I would just
watch and but but if you practice the
sport and you discuss it with others and
you also like have a habit of watching
it eventually you start to pick up the
patterns like a child who is learning to
see objects H you learn to see moves in
Jujitsu and the the same thing happens
with more abstract truths as well that's
basically what happens with um I think
moral truths um there's even this good
theory I think by Jonathan I and a few
of his colleagues about um um moral
foundations Theory um he says that we
it's kind of like with per with visual
perception let's say there's all kinds
of photons in our eyes there's like all
this multiplicity but it takes time for
us to turn that multiplicity into
coherent patterns to make out the world
in the same way we seem to have basic
moral intuitions um that we use to make
up more complex moral judgments like we
have disgust that uh like is a very
basic emotion that protects us from
pathogens and um dangerous um substances
in general but it's also a moral emotion
that we end up exacting to um reject
certain injustices or um let's say um
ideas that are also pathogens for our
tribe and this kind of stuff so like he
has I think this good theory where you
can see how there's like the these basic
senses that we have to perceive
initially just chaotic multiplicity in
the moral realm but as we grow up and we
try to practice our moral uh perceptions
we end up being able to perceive more
and more complex patterns yeah um but
it's it's important to say just just as
you as you go through this that
understand that what's important to
understand in what you said is that it
makes the analogies real that that when
we use the analogy for example if we say
you know that that this person is
parasite on the system that the analogy
between and even the mechanism by which
we recognize a parasite let's say coming
towards something dirty something that
that is that is dangerous uh physically
is the same mechanism that we use to
then see the moral or societal
parasite yeah and also like it like
having this Continuum of like when you
understand that perception is something
you need to practice not just in
Morality but also even just to perceive
very basic objects it makes it really
hard to reject moral realism on the
basis of varieties between different
nations or groups or tribes for instance
because if you were to look also at
developing infants like they also can't
really see the world like they're
they're very confused it it takes a long
time for them to be able to perceive
like faces and objects and pick things
up and like it's something we need to
practice the same way that if like
you're just starting to do Jiu-Jitsu you
won't perceive what's happening yeah
you'll be confused and it's going to
take longer for you to perceive
Jiu-Jitsu moves then uh to perceive like
basic objects when you're an infant like
in the same way it's going to take like
all of your life to improve your moral
perception and still then like you
probably won't be able to see everything
perfectly unless you become a saint so
it's not surprising that different
cultures disagree about like how they
perceive morality it just like so so the
these kinds of ideas were able to like
destroy my moral relativism and in like
immediately when that happened
my zombie nightmares were again cut down
by like 50 or 60 or 90% so at that point
I was starting to have like way less
zombie nightmares I still had some but
like it was very manageable I honestly
thought it would just stay like this
forever um but because I was supporting
you on patreon we had like these regular
chats and we became friends and at some
point uh I asked you like what would you
do like if if you were in my position
where like okay you were having a zombie
nightmare right now uh like you're the
you're the main character in a zombie
story let's see what do you do like
what's the what's the solution how can I
get out of this and we ended up working
through it together do you remember what
the solution was you don't remember yeah
I remember what it was actually we we
also like further improved it I think um
two three years ago on the French
podcast but the initial solution was uh
like it took us a few iterations to
figure something out but the basic idea
we came up with was to do what Jesus
would do um
because like zombies are you've talked
about this on your channel before
zombies are a parody of the Christian
Resurrection they're really a parody of
the the Christian World viw specifically
the Christian apocalypse because zombies
come back to life but they don't have
this glorious body they just have this
decaying body uh they are all together
but rather than being in communion they
just like follow the Imp their impulses
in the same Direction uh they look let's
say unique and special but it's only
superficial really the only like all
want to eat is the same thing uh they um
like they they eat brains because it's
the Last Remnant of meaning in the
materialistic Universe like they're
trying to destroy like the only thing
that doesn't fit quite right in the
materialistic worldview like even if
they try to to deny it so anyways
there's all these parallels um between
um zombies and cushan where zombies are
trying to basically destroy the ancient
meaning systems and um there's also the
key I think in Jesus's story against
this again uh well to trample down death
by death so Jesus even today like in the
Eucharist he lets us eat him but doing
that he actually eats us the same way
that he he let us kill him 2,000 years
ago in a way that would bring us into
his story to make us Saint so like
there's this key inside of Christ story
and we could go deeper into many details
like what we do especially during the
Eucharistic lurgy is the exact antidote
to the the meaning crisis and the zombie
crisis because zombies uh like they they
just grown they can't make sounds um but
we sing when we're in the church zombies
just like jumble up to eat stuff and
Destroy stuff thinking only about
themselves but we're in church we're
praying for one another we're being
thankful towards the same thing rather
than just consuming everything for
ourselves so there there's all these
parallels you can make U to see how
Christianity is the specifically
participating in L in lury is the
solution to the zombie problem and what
we came up with was okay then what you
would need to do is like somehow let
yourself be eaten by zombies um like you
would have to do
something like spirit like like pray or
like find some way in your zombie
Universe to become a saint and then you
let yourself be eaten by zombies to save
even the zombies um and when we worked
through that then my nightmares
disappeared I never had one since then
the the only times I add some after were
when I would explicitly be trying to
write about my experiences for others
but I never add this again for myself
the the dreams just went away yeah and
what's crazy about that is that we kind
of we did came up with this like like a
story almost like a narrative about the
idea of a a a saint like like that that
get that REM remain that lets himself be
eaten and then wakes up truly let's say
resurrects truly doesn't come back as a
zombie but comes back as a as a kind of
Glorious being in the zombie story uh
and it's weird because it seems like
that's a story that should exist like
somebody should write it you know that
the idea because I don't think that
exists the idea of a zombie that wakes
up from his state and and retrieves you
know a kind of even a a better level of
Consciousness that they had before so
you know that's out there folks whoever
does it you know if you don't do it I at
some point I'll write it myself just
because that story has to exist yeah I
think the closest I've seen is worm
bodies um it was made into a movie but
there was also a book from few years ago
uh but the zombie doesn't come back to a
glorious body let's say he comes back to
the like same kind of existence um and
there's like interesting I I think um
let say facets of the Christian story
you can see in that movie and especially
in the book like in the book there's
almost a baptism scene at some point the
the the zombie um like he's starting to
wake up basically out of love for one
girl uh because he ate the brains of his
uh his boyfriend uh but like he ends up
like slowly like developing feelings
towards that girl and he saves her
spends time with her and like through
this attraction he becomes more and more
human but at some point he has to make
like a kind of confession and there's a
kind of baptism scene like in front of a
church when it's raining uh and he's
washing his mouth from blood um because
it just ate someone like but he didn't
want to anyway like there's this
progression and the the zombie
ultimately spoiler alert uh shut shut
this down if you don't want to read uh
the the book or watch the film but at
the end uh the zombie comes back to
normal human life by sacrificing himself
for that girl so like he has to
basically like wrap himself around her
as they're getting shot and he has to
like Drop in like a building I think and
like he's thinking he's going to die
doing that but he eventually like drops
in a pool so again there's this water
baptism thing and then when he comes
back like he sees that he's bleeding so
he's become human again so um like you
can see glamors I think in popular
culture of this this solution but as you
said I don't think anyone has come up
with the full um narrative Arc so far
yeah yeah yeah well that's part of the
that that part of what's coming over the
hill let's say on storytelling you know
it seems like it's a perfect story to
tell so so basically that was the that
is kind of what healed you but that also
kind of that involved going back to
church it involved getting married it
like your whole life changed really yeah
yeah yeah yeah I think as soon as soon
as I worked out the let's see moral
layer as soon as I could see that okay I
have a metaphysics where it's starting
to be possible to talk about Good and
Evil um then I started going back to
church I I was brought up Catholic um I
had done my sacraments when I was uh a
child so I just came back and uh
eventually like found a really good
Parish here uh there's sort of this um
blessing uh in Disguise that we have
here like in Quebec the church collapsed
so much that the people who are left are
actually like really trying to do it for
the right reasons and like it becomes
really clear examples of what to follow
so found a really great Parish here
pretty quickly got involved with
um different groups that really helped
me found uh the woman that I married and
now that I have a son with and uh yeah
like like as you said this intellectual
path really followed also a um a
concrete like embodied path in a in a
community that I was lucky to find so
yeah this big path of of transformation
and no more zombie nightmares no more
nihilism
and so that has helped you in some ways
because one of the things that I've been
impressed by you is that the fact that
you you really have studied philosophy
quite a bit and you know you've talked a
lot with John RI with several people
that are in this in this sphere and so
you've been able to talk about symbolism
in a more technical way using more
philosophical language and that is what
the book is going to be and that in some
ways is what the class is going to be to
help people uh have more precise
language even a langu that is closer to
the ones that you'll hear in University
and stuff because both mats and I mats
developed really his own language which
is very powerful and and beautiful um
but I also recognize that some people
they when they try to explain it to
their friends in school they struggle to
find the the way to link it to to the to
the and I have the same problem people
accuse me of being imprecise of not
using the right words and not knowing
the right words and so I'm really happy
to see this this as a possibility to
help kind of bolster the case so maybe
you can tell us a bit about what the
thesis is and what it is you're hoping
to accomplish with it yeah uh
so I I'm trying to aim the book
specifically for people who were sort of
in my in the position where I was 10
years ago where you're in the course of
a um an education focused on science and
you're developing this sort of
materialism as a result and you
wondering if there's another
solution and for I think people of this
um kind of character the arguments as
they're sometimes presented will be a
bit too fast like phenomenology didn't
work for me like I it it like either it
wouldn't click or I would sort of
understand what you were saying but I
think it was going too fast and I it was
going to make me drop some of the like
value that I saw in physics and math
like there's stuff that I just let's say
loved too much still in that scientific
worldview to be able to drop it too
quickly with uh phenomenology I know
that ultimately like you can recover
physics from phenomenology but at first
it does feel like you're abandoning
something that uh you really love so um
as you said I'm glad you're doing that
because I don't have I don't have like a
specific love for physics myself so it's
good that you that you're
doing but and as you said what ended up
happening is like okay so I had this
love for for still the physical uh
especially physical science that um I
was trying to like still use in uh my my
studies I was talking with you to try to
get more into the symbolic world view I
was also talking with John Riki um about
the cognitive science side and also in
in general he was great on the the
physics side um and I was always trying
to bridge mainly between you and John I
would say um and it took it took several
years I would often like run arguments
by you and by him and like try to see if
I can make something most of our
conversations you and I Jonathan were uh
in private on like for patreon chats
with John all of my discussions are
public on my Channel or on uh his
channel
but basically as you said um like
through this I developed I think pretty
carefully a path from materialism all
the way to um the symbolic world uh like
and even up to the more let's say
esoteric um debates in symbolism like
how is it exactly that the world exists
in in Christ and how is it that the
world exists through human consciousness
and like all of these more esoteric kind
of questions um you can get there pretty
quickly with phenomenology but as I said
this was too much for me so I go I went
at it very slowly and I try to document
it uh in in the book so um the main
thesis is that we're in in a meaning
crisis because of materialistic
reductionism I Ed the zombie myth to
talk about it and then um I tried to the
the way that I tried to do it to to go
slowly as I said is I try to show like
within science itself there's no good
way anymore to be a reductionist uh this
is like in 19th century view of science
it doesn't work not only can you still
have your science including your physics
today by going toward non-reductive
materialism non-reductive naturalism
sorry you'll even have like a better
science a better physics to love so I'm
trying to really like give something to
materialists so they don't have to drop
anything they actually just have
something better so that's the first
part of the book where I try to take
people from materialism to non-reductive
naturalism which is really just
classical metaphysics like if you if you
read um let's say um like what classical
metaphysicians wrote uh using Aristotle
or Plato like in the last few centuries
like you'll see something that HS really
well modern
non-reductionist uh naturalism and in
the book I go through it carefully but
there's arguments really coming from
both like the top and the bottom like
there's all kinds of arguments that
popped up in philosophy and cognitive
science about the impossibility of
reducing the mind to matter and even
like in general the idea that there are
those emergent properties that you can't
reduce to lower entities so it shows up
in chemistry in in biology and the most
obvious case is with Consciousness um
like you won't find many people now in
philosophy of mind or cognitive science
who think that the mind is just a matter
of particles or neurons let's say um so
this there's this like problem coming
from the top but there are also problems
coming from the bottom uh in physics
where
like things always get iffy when you
talk about Quantum stuff because people
like can defend easily New Age ideas
about this I know I never talk about
that stuff just because I know what the
problem that it brings yeah but but but
there's a real problem for people who
want to be materialist there because
like if you're materialist and you want
to reduce things down to particles like
you have to be able to talk about those
particles but like you're going to enter
into like new AG territory pretty fast
because it doesn't look like what you
see down there is stable particles like
you can see like fields and you can
mathematize them and there's interesting
stuff to say but it's definitely not
stable particles like at best it's
probability fields that you can quantify
but as you do that you're starting to
like go towards stuff that is closer and
closer to the prime matter that the
classical metaphys metaphysicians talked
about and another problem coming from
physics is that and that's something
coming from physicalists uh themselves
is like there's no
we don't know what physical entities are
like even by Nature physics doesn't tell
you what its entities are it tells you
how they behave like it only gives you
equations and even if Physicians tell
you like the mass and charge of the
electron is this or that all that means
is that if you put such and such values
in an equation you'll get this and this
Behavior but you actually never know
what physical entities are in physics so
like if you're trying to reduce things
down to particles let's say and you're a
materialist like you're in big trouble
because it doesn't look like what you
have at the bottom are stable particles
and you don't even know like what is
their nature you know how the waves
behave let's say but you don't know why
or what they are fundamentally so
there's like these big problems if you
want to be a modern naturalist of like
there seems to be irreducible stuff at
the top and there also seem to be
something like TR matter at the bottom
but like that's perfect if you just
consider Aristotle and Plato and like
the whole classical metaphysical
tradition because in that world viiew
what you have at the top are irreducible
forms and what you have at the bottom is
prime matter and the world exists in a
hierarchy between them um like the
classical metaphysicians didn't quite
use the words that John biki use uses
for that but I think it's great like is
terminology of emanation top down and
emergence bottom up I think that's a
great way of explaining it like from
potentiality things emerge but if you
just add this bottom up emergence like
it would be impossible to explain why
things coair so you also need this top
down comination of forms these patterns
that
allow potential to cohere into actual
entities so that's the first part of the
book like how you can retrieve a
classical worldview uh where you not you
not only have this ontology of like
matter and form in a hierarchy but you
also have forms that have to do with
vices and virtues like you can recover
what I said earlier about perception the
fact that okay you learn to perceive
objects but also vices and virtues so
you recover a sense of Good and Evil
you're you're already starting to leave
nihilism behind um you're not quite up
to Christianity yet and a full solution
to the zombie problem but at least like
you're not a nihilistic materialist
anymore and what I like about doing it
this slowly is that there's nothing that
the scientist loses at this stage like
it's just positive like you basically
take the entire science that the
scientist had but you take his
ontological hierarchy and you just make
it a bit bigger so that what he has
makes more sense but it doesn't have to
drop anything so that's that's the first
part of the book and then the second
part of the book what I do is I try to
go further by saying okay Christianity
is still the full solution like uh I
can't justify Christianity fully using
arguments coming from naturalism or
materialism I think like if you could
fully justify Christianity using
something lower you would actually be
reducing Christianity to something lower
I think the way that truth Works in
general is you have to rather like try
to seduce people into something higher
so um what I try to do is a lot like
what Lewis did in his book Miracles but
I do it for modern naturalism now I say
if you take the pattern of the
Incarnation now and you try to
see the ontological hierarchy you try to
see the natural world in the light of
the Incarnation the natural the natural
world actually makes more sense and it's
the same way that any new theory is
Advanced even in science like the way
that Newton for instance Advanced his
theory of relativity was exactly this
like he came up with new aums that
people thought were crazy by the way
people thought Newton was proposing
something occult because he was
proposing a force that acted as a
distance whereas everyone back then was
a mechanist like people thought that
everything was just like basically Bard
bilard balls and like things pulling and
pushing against one another so people
thought there was like something like
material explaining why were attracted
to the Earth but because Newton said it
was just a force acting at a distance
people thought he was insane but because
he was able to seduce them they actually
ended up agreeing with him because he
said okay just I know it doesn't make
sense from your like standpoint but if
you grant me what I'm proposing then
you're going to have all that you have
right now and more so he basically ended
up like seducing people and now we think
nothing of it like of course gravity of
course for is acting at a distance but
I'm trying to do do the same for the
Incarnation I'm trying to say okay like
the Incarnation seems crazy like it
seems to be too much from a naturalistic
standpoint even a non-reductive
naturalist but actually I think that if
you take the Incarnation you'll be able
to get all of what you had before and
more again so I'm trying to seduce
people into it and um we talked I'm I'm
making use of much of the stuff we
discussed a few years ago related to
Miracles especially at the miracle of
the Incarnation I think like it it just
makes so much sense of even the
experience I had doing mathematics when
I was a student
because and it it just blows my mind any
anytime I think about it let's say if I
try to prove a theorem let's say even
something basic like the Pythagorean
theorem I'm taking an abstract truth
that exists outside of space and time
like even if there was no physical
Universe the Pythagorean theor would
still be
true and yet when I'm thinking about
this like somehow all of my neurons
like are assembling to OST this
immaterial truth so there there's this
crazy bridge that happens in human
beings when we Ponder Eternal truths
and I think the world makes more sense
if it's made for this like if at its
root like this this bridge is just an
image of the bridge that happens in the
Incarnation where the creator of the
forms and matter comes and embeds
himself into that great hierarchy so
that's just one example but you can find
so many let's say aspects of nature
aspect of this ontological hierarchy
that you find in non-reductive
naturalism that are better explained if
you take the Incarnation as the key that
ultimately I think like people should be
seduced into the story of the
Incarnation and mythologically also what
this does is a solution to the zombie
crisis I opened the book with like a
solution to uh I opened the book with
the zombie myth to explain our
reductionistic
materialistic standpoint but as I also
said earlier ultimately is the Eucharist
it's self-sacrifice that is the full
solution to the zombie problem and I
want to invite people into that story uh
I want to I want to seduce people into
the story of the Incarnation I think I
provide a solution to the zombie problem
and also in metaphysics I give people
something that makes more sense than
just non-reductive naturalism um so
that's the main thrust of the book like
I try to take people from materialistic
reductionism to classical metaphysics
where they're not nihilists anymore
where good and evil exist and then I try
to take them all the way into the story
of the Incarnation where like all
zombies are vanquished all the zombies
are van I I I mean like I think it's
exciting because it seems like it's also
just the right moment for that to to
come out because we have all these
people all these surprising moments like
Ayan hery I who's says she's a Christian
she's liter i' I've heard that she's
there's gonna there's a debate organized
between her and Dawkins like they're
gonna actually debate that all of a
sudden so the the all of these things
happening you even have uh people like
Brett Weinstein who are also kind of
moving in a Direction saying oh this
isn't work anymore this is in some ways
this is over like this world this kind
of 19th century
uh thinking is done um and so it's a
it's a wonderful time Jordan Peterson's
next book is called uh um we struggle
with God and he's going through the
Bible and he's doing a similar thing to
what you're doing which is he says says
by the time people finish reading this
they'll just be no room for atheism uh
anymore so this is a perfect time for
all this to come together so how do you
see the course going through going with
this like how do you see the class
coming together yeah good question
basically
the
more the the more advanced topics I
decided to keep for the course I want
the book to be more general public let's
say so there's no need to go into some
of the more Niche symbolic World topics
like I think it's important for people
who are really interested to know like
what distinguishes the symbolical
metaphysics from let's say per peral
metaphysics uh or Universalist
metaphysics I think it's important to
try to see like more precisely
interesting stuff like how it is that
the world exists in uh in Christ how it
is that the world comes to exist through
human consciousness um but I don't think
it's necessary to go into those topics
for a general audience that is just
trying to get out of nihilism so um
basically my Approach was to take the
course as an opportunity to dive deeper
into uh more advanced topics that I
think will be interested interesting to
the symbolic World audience people who
have some background in symbolism um but
uh I also cover everything that is in
the book so if someone just wants to
work through the arguments carefully
like in a setting with other people and
ask questions I think the course is
going to be a great place to do so um
and for people who want more who want
stuff that is not going to be in the
book uh if people want to hear more
about the more difficult aspects of
symbolic World metaphysics the course is
going to be a great place to delve into
those topics so this is I mean to me it
seems like an like an exciting thing I
and I know because I can see that I mean
I see it I see that people have
questions let's say that I don't
necessarily have and so they have issues
because they they they're trying to
connect kind of the symbolic thinking
with other aspects that are not the ones
that I either know or uh that are let's
say in the Forefront of my of my mind
and so this is really important for
people who have those kind of specific
questions and people who are also you
know we all have
we all have our strength and our
capacity to do certain things and and
I'm really grateful that you're there to
also provide some a little more
technical specificity to how this works
and trying to say you know try to work
it out in a more detailed way it's
useful for everybody especially people
that are in the symbolic World kind of
thinking and kind of roaming around that
that way of seeing the world but they
also are in University or they're in
grad school and they or they even some
some people like they even have
positions in universities and you know
they they're starting to think that way
but they're struggling sometimes to
justify to their peers and to be able to
explain it to the people around them so
this is a very useful thing you're doing
yeah I think now is also a good time to
do it because it's still close enough to
me like I can tell that um let's see as
um as Christianity in the symbolic world
you becomes more second nature to me
like it it it takes more thought to put
myself back back into the shoes of a
reductionistic materialist so I can I
can feel that it like it could slip like
in 10 years it would be much harder for
me to write the book than it it was now
um and I think the same thing is going
to happen to a lot of people like
ideally if the book can save time for
people who are at the point where I was
10 years ago that's great and then they
can forget about it and move on to just
like sing the world uh symbolically um
but yeah uh as you said I think now is a
is a good time to do it if there's lots
of people going through through this
transition if I can save them a lot of
time I think this is great uh and it
would be harder to do like at some point
as more and more people see the world
this way like it's going to be harder to
document the transition exactly how it
works yeah because I mean our prediction
both my brother and I's prediction and I
think D Peterson told me he had a
similar Insight when he wrote math of
meaning it he said you know in 25 years
everybody's going to think this way and
no one will know that they've change the
way they think and so uh I think that
for those of us that are at the outset
of this and that are kind of helping to
instigate the change uh it's useful for
us to be clear on what's going on as we
notice it kind of infuses the
backgrounds of people's minds and change
the world view uh slowly so wonderful
stuff I'm I will be there in the class
folks I'll be there not in every single
episode but I'll be there at the
beginning maybe a few times during it
and I'll definitely be there at the at
the last class to kind of to wrap it all
up so I'm looking forward to seeing
people there and to uh and to follow
along and you know this year like how
can I say this like everything now covid
after Co ended things are kind of
starting to consolidate I feel you know
we have the symbolic World Press now
we're going to start to publish not just
my works but also works of people like
John Philip that are in the symbolic
world and that are thinking about this
and that have really worked out some
aspects so both fiction and non-fiction
so it's a it's a great time to to to
jump in and to get involved we did the
baywolf class it was massively
successful and I think we'll see
something similar with this class as
well so people sign up the class is what
did we say the first dat was it going to
be we just the
24th yeah the 24th January 24th so
January 24th is the first class sign up
we'll put a link in the descriptions of
course you can you can sign up and uh
and we'll have questions there it it is
a mix of lecture and interaction and uh
we're looking forward to seeing you guys
there and the book is going to be ready
for the summit basically that is the
plan the plan is to have a pre launch at
the summit so if you come to the summit
you'll be able to get early copies of
the book uh and then after that we'll
have a more official more official
launch so good stuff perfect thanks
Jonathan yeah thanks thanks you I want
to invite you all to the very first
symbolic World Summit over 3 days we
will finally meet in real time in real
space and everyone from this little
corner of the internet we be there to
explore the theme of reclaiming the
cosmic image of course I will will be
speaking but there will also be Martin
Shaw who is an amazing mythographer
father Steven D young of Lord of spirit
Fame there will be Richard Roland from
the universal history series Vesper
Stamper Nicholas kotar and Neil deg gr
that you've all seen on my channel here
and there for entertainment we have
everyone's favorite apocalyptic band The
One and Only dirt po Robins this event
will be the chance of a lifetime to
capture and embrace our current moment
so join us from February 29th to March
2nd 2024 in Tarpon spings Florida visit
the symbolic
world.com Summit for more information
and I will see you
there